hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast in-house technology
development for next gene sequencing
tissue handling and beyond at the BC
Cancer Agency presented by Robin coop an
instrumentation group leader at BC
Cancer Agency genome Center I'm Suzy
Valdez of labyrinth and I will be your
moderator for today's event
we're excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth of eating scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone that
today's presentation is interactive we
want to hear from you so questions
comments they can be submitted via the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
your screen once there as many questions
as we have time for at the end of our
presentation also you are viewing the
presentation in a slide window to
enlarge that window click on the icon at
the lower right hand corner of your
slide window if you cannot hear or see
this presentation properly let us know
by clicking on the support button at the
top right or the Q&A button to let us
know that you're having a problem
without further ado let me turn our
presentation over to Robin coop welcome
sir centers in Vancouver I would like to
talk to you today about some of the
automation and other sort of custom
device development that we could hear at
the genome Sciences Center
I should say I'm going to talk a little
bit about automated site selection and I
am a board member of a spin-off company
we have cultural genomics in that area
the outline of my talk is to talk about
liquid handling strategies at the genome
Sciences Center that we are employing
here is a fairly large-scale automation
effort some of the in health projects we
do smaller projects a big in health
project all automated site selection
talk a little bit about how we do
prototyping because I think we have some
unique abilities there that I believe
other people should have a little bit of
an automated methods for improving tumor
contact which is kind of our current big
project and build a lot on the things
that we've learned from the previous
project speed projects we've done and
finally then the lessons
that we've heard from those big projects
and how we're applying them now
liquid enabling robotics with the GFC we
are one of Canada's largest Genome
Sciences centers Gino Gino McEwin Seng
facilities so our primary focus is
really on on cancer and we do a mixture
of research samples and not just cancer
we do do many other things too noble
genomes and bacterial genomes we do also
a variety of doctors whole genomes but a
lot of RNA seek as well so we have a
variety of different strategies I should
say we also do clinical sequencing and
that also is primarily right now over
various targeted strategies so so this
actually means there's a number of
pipelines but the pipelines that are all
related fundamentally in the DNA
sequencing library construction on
Illumina and really most other
sequencers it's basically the same you
have a number of steps where you make
small fragments somehow of DNA which can
come from RNA or may come from FFP or
may have come from whole genome Express
you make them small you add adapters and
then you have to do some purification or
potentially some amplification and
quantification
so we in fact have it's hard to keep
track but somewhere between seven and
nine strategies primary pipelines whole
genome PCR free from fresh to what we
call small gap which is libraries used
for capture such as primarily SOS but
any targeted capture panel the status
specific RNA seek for micro RNA isolated
micro RNA isolation will rival diffusion
so there's some different rays coming in
to RNA to get mRNA which you've been are
turning into cDNA and sequencing some
some heavy genomics strategies and then
FFP and frozen tissue is an input which
of course means SR ffe as distinct from
frozen tissues where you have fragmented
libraries which may also be damaged
which require some different steps and
now an emerging thing is circulating
cell free DNA which is generally small
fragments of double-stranded DNA that
have to be purified and then are may be
in small abundance or the part you're
looking at for non-invasive prenatal
testing or potentially cancer are small
fragments or small fractions of the
total that you're looking for
all these need to be in version control
pipelines and we have a bunch of
different robots because you've got DNA
you've got the breast tissue extraction
and RNA processing and then you've got
pre PCR activities knew about post-pc
our activities and you've got
quantification in rearranged essentially
upstream and downstream that produces a
lot of code the strategy we use is to
have first of all harmonize our robots
as much as we can and then organize our
library construction methods so the
robot memorization has been - we've
migrated from an older generation the
Human Genome Project era a set of
violent robots and for provided reasons
that aren't important we have gone to
some different Lots currently we will
shortly have a final platform
or system we're looking at to the next
few years which is a perfect over
giannis off screen and a mini Janus at
the very end of the pipeline and then
seven Nimbus is primals and Nimbus
robots in the middle so what we have is
for biospecimens which means
quantification Andreea rates you have
this Janus upstream and then we have a
couple of robots and tissue extraction
and RNA constants in three robots in pre
pcr activities - robots in post PCR
activities which is primarily cleanups
post PCR cleanups on qualification and
then a Janus another jobs at the end for
some qPCR setup and pooling which goes
into DNA sequencing we wish to automate
the whole things as much as possible
exception quantification normalization
library construction and cooling we want
to automate liquid transfers we're not
currently thinking about or we haven't
worked on automating or completely walk
away automation so that we have
incubation automated at this point so we
set we setup place with reactions and
then we incubate them and so there's a
certain amount of manual activity in
there but we use a game by playing in
that direction and finally and most
importantly in a way currently with
next-gen sequencing we're using a lot of
relatively we have lots of sample sets
which are cold plates there's lots of
sub plate work that needs to be you
would still regard we do it in an
automated way and not manually
and so we're using very much offset
pipetting to handle a range of batch
sizes so we can go anywhere from within
a column of a plate to an entire plate
what that looks like is shown in this
slide where you have the robot simply
pick up one column of tips or two or
three columns of tips and then you can
process as many samples as you want this
is picking up out of kouvaris tube rack
which is for curing DNA which is another
tricky pipetting thing that we've built
some hardware custom hardware for for
automating so you can see this muscle
work can go into automating some of
these tricky steps so this means that we
can process any back size of samples and
it currently particular genome
sequencing for tensor title sequencing
or or you know our big personalized aqua
genomics research project we're trying
to we typically going to be batching
quite often and therefore we often want
to batch it maybe 24 samples or 48
samples and not batch of 96 samples
because we need to turn around samples
you know within a one week time frame a
person is going to depend on the size of
the jurisdiction that you're doing these
things in but in British Columbia with
our scale of our publicly funded
clinical panel of sequencing activity in
the health system it makes sense to
batch at this sort of substrate volume
and so it's quite important to do up a
penny and therefore efficiently run
these pipelines so anyway we've got all
of these pipelines that are basically
doing library construction and so we
want to hybridize these things in order
to not have an absolutely nightmare of
code control and you can imagine that we
are talking about seven or nine or
whatever depending on you counted
different pipelines and we're talking
about all of them having be
purifications and reaction setups and if
you if you if you start to let those
things drift in these different
parameters and different pipelines you
promote some a code management point
this is an absolute nightmare also what
it means is you can you can abandon old
pipelines in haven't been worked on for
a while they can actually become sort of
increasingly relatively speaking much
more inefficient and even you end up
having an oil pipeline that has a
dramatically too much DNA going into it
by modern standards and so keeping all
this stuff moving forward and yet under
control is the challenge so
here so here's what we're doing right
obtain DNA and RNA fresh from fresh
tissue or or FFP D or cell free DNA and
then you go you make DNA or if you have
RNA then you do end repair you do bead
purification you do additional ligation
PCR for some libraries level you do that
some kind of purification which could be
a site selection what purification out
of the adapters and maybe some tighter
site selection and then at the end you
do some QC so what we've done is
actually right this is primarily on
Nimbus uh we write this programming
structure where the read steps that you
see here are actually all one method so
on the red in the column be clean of all
sorts basically one method that has
different volumes passed to it as
arguments depending on what pipeline
you're in and the amount of samples you
have in some cases be the size of the
fragment that you're dealing with
because they can vary a little bit and
the blue steps are the same reaction
setups as you can see if you look at the
columns we have statuses of exceeding
they synthesis we have this is a SS RNA
seek we have PCR or genome chip I
sulfide G DNA from FFP PTR free and so
forth and so they all have slightly
different steps but you can actually
manage this with one program so what
this looks like for the user is the on
the left you see the the first window
that they would see which is please
select library type and then once you
select one of those we've selected PCR
free in this case it asks what stage of
library searching are you doing you may
have stopped part way through and then
you can go ahead and then it produces
pictures of the the definitely ups that
you should have at that point and so
people lay things down on the desk
technologist and we've done from there
so so this there's a whole lot of
advantages to this in that you can
really kind of keep track of best
practices to you'll find it you'll
potentially find errors in one pipeline
but you realize that there is the
potentially propagate to other pipelines
you catch them first
maybe it's advantage that they do
propagate to other pipelines but in fact
they because that they were all isolated
they wouldn't but in fact you catch the
errors quickly and so you can quickly
make everything better in all pipelines
um so on that note yeah the big thing
ten times less code to manage probably
or something on that scale
keep your be clean parameters and
reaction set up as good as they can be
you can catch her as quickly
the downside is it's potentially less
flexible if new methods arrive and you
have to bring them into the Harmonized
strategy um that probably would have
been a bigger problem maybe four five
years ago but we've started to see a
certain amount of maturing of library
construction methods where particularly
bead purification for example we've
gotten we think really good at it and
and we we don't really see those because
those discrimination strategies changing
a lot of the pipetting methods changing
a lot so you have some little things you
may add you know different different
reagents different enzymes and different
reaction steps but but the type ending
methods are fundamentally dirty textures
the same so we can add steps and keep it
within the overall harmonized structure
and and from from my point of view as
the the leader the people who are
responsible for managing the code I'm
very satisfied with the harmonization
strategy so when I talk about an
in-house engineering project we do by
group actually has more people it has
two engineers come actually from
engineering training and two folks from
biology who have good programming skills
one of whom is a absolute master of
Excel which is kind of neat because of
course in high throughput genomics we're
always battling between expelling and
sort of in health laboratory on
information management but anyway we got
a great team and so I guess the the Roma
programming I describe to you just now
is done by largely one dedicated guy who
works hand in hand with the biology
method developers but is supported by
the engineering teams to do either the
more difficult code or generating custom
hardware such as when we want to pipette
in and out of cohorts place or other
kind of custom adapter
things we've done a lot of our own
incubator systems for ER incubators for
upstream tissue extraction for example
on deck the engineers then also do these
kinds of in-house projects so it's a few
fun examples that are currently minor
but but
cool this is what we call the cryo cart
and the cryo crane so essentially we
have a cart that's used for shipping
sample tea time all of these this is
basically stuff that the cart the crime
report goes out to as far away as Uganda
gets filled with samples for a variety
of projects you've got some HIV - more
molecular characterizations and perfect
lymphoma project to get silver samples
in Uganda and without having to be
returned to that regime they come back
so the route of managing liquid nitrogen
making sure you have enough and so forth
so we built this crane structure and we
run the 2012 WorkSafeBC PIRG anomic
innovation contest which got my entire
team and the blue team a freelancer so
I'm proud of that I also proud of the
modified my sleep tray that we did and
this was a project very much different
by automatic so discussion with our
biomedics friends who back when the mice
eat was running 150 base reads we asked
could you double the reagent volume and
make a pair 10 300 read and if you could
do that could you make a paradigm 300
read that would overlap you made an
insert that was say 500 bases and then
they would overlap so as the read length
declined as he got longer and longer you
would actually have the read sort of
merged and and be able to be error
checked against each other in the middle
in 50 at the distal ends of the reads
thereby making a 5 or 600 base construct
that that includes in the end we did
apparent 520 bite to a pen into 50 kit
and you could make these contacts that
were really good for de novo sequencing
and so in fact we publish the paper of
automatics on assembling the 20 gigabase
white spruce genome using this method as
you can see we've taken a reagent tray
from a my seat this again goes back to
about 2012 and take a reagent tray and
colorful and manufacture a larger
reservoir and we had a method for
cracking open the region tray and then
adding double the reagents from two kits
and then doing these really long reads
and I'm very pleased with this project
because it was the driver for the
project came straight from automatic if
you guys could do this this would really
be cool as the computational level and
so we were able to auger a singing
hardware that gave better data in the
end and
some good things um much bigger project
now automated site selection this goes
originally back to about 2009 but some
importantly was involved in the human in
the Cancer Genome Atlas Project which is
the a major project in understanding
molecular tumors that was from around
2009 to mm well I guess it sort of
continues on to the day - doesn't call
13 with the main sample run so the idea
here was the realization that we could
with a good automation we could do whole
whole sample separation
simply put DNA this would be a
constructed library so it's it's
fragments with an adapter with adapters
on both ends you load them into gels so
what we have here is a channels of gel
and you run them out using individual
control of the electric field in each in
each channel that's done with pulse
width modulation um you then need some
kind of markers so the camera can come
along and take photographs and it can
take it can identify the fraction of
interest by looking at where it is
relative to a some marker which I'll
tell you in a second to how we do this
in micro RNA and then it moves down you
can see at the bottom there there's an
extraction well and so the target of
interest goes to the extraction well and
gets pulled out and so the the the
reason that you need individual control
of each of each channel is that you need
to actually schedule the arrival of each
fragment when we redid it originally we
have single channel here so we do that
with you do one after another and in
fact you can do it you can do probably
place on the robot at one time so this
gives you 96 size collection now it
turns out that our lab did all of the
site selections for the Cancer Genome
Atlas Project which was on the order of
11,000 micro rna's I think in total we
did a lot of micro mRNA prior to
subsequent to that and so probably
20,000 samples were running this
platform over all the way that micro RNA
size selection works or work is that the
adapter dimer is about 88 bases and the
adapter micro RNA adapter construct is
only about 120 or 110 bases so we were
essentially pulling out a small fragment
right
the linker dimer and that was the
adapter dimer sorry and that's the micro
RNA cause-effect if you want a sequence
and as I say this enabled the entire
pipeline for micro RNA here at the GFC
so how do we do these things I wanted to
pause on the lab devices here and kind
of explain a bit about prototyping we
have a great collaboration with the
Cancer Agency actually in lots of areas
of course we're doing clinical
sequencing we're doing all kinds of
other medical collaborations with the
folks in the hospital radiation Medical
Physics people other oncologists and so
forth one of the things we have is in a
medical physics department there is a
machine shop which which with some
research funding we did a joint we've
done a partnership to essentially
upgrade their birthing facilities and
make it so we can do some amazing
prototyping in the right in the main
cancer clinic in downtown right here in
Vancouver so we've been doing this now
for about 10 years and a big part of
this is actually the type of process
when we do so so what is effective
prototyping well first of all you want a
quick turnaround time so you need your
engineers and your designers to actually
be able to have the possibility of
making things themselves so that they
can think about the design and work on
it or iterated rapidly without make
attendings away and then wait for a long
time you could just never make parts
fast enough because the more chances you
have to make and iterate designs and
test them the better your ultimate
design is likely to be another problem
another sort of challenge that sort of
stands in opposition to that is that
your prototypes in a lab like this
they're not really if you to build
something for the lab you need to do it
efficiently but then it needs to
actually be really well finished as
though it's but it's a finished product
that is something that you purchase
because otherwise the lab people they
don't really want to use your crappy
prototype they want to use a thing in
the lab that feels and looks
professional so you need to finish
things properly and in fact as a final
thing if you're going to imagine doing
something that might be a spin-off
technology the the cost of prototyping
or or the the road to get to
thing that you could actually sell I
nearly needs to be as short as possible
because it turns out that is the
development of the prototype can be a
huge part of the manufacturing cost so
if you can go in with the low product
cost because your development costs as
well this is super helpful and this is
very true of instruments where you have
a small number of units that you're
going to sell and you can't amortize
over many you can amort amortize your
development cost over many items you
sell traditional prototyping and these
are my classic examples of a milling
machine in the lathe involved setting up
on certain types of machines more modern
than these the basically the same idea
is you're cutting you're cutting
aluminum steel and plastic on milling
machines and lathes the workholding
grabbing the part in such a way and
reposition it becomes the limiting step
but it takes a lot of experience so but
you can already working with more
challenging materials you need sort of
specialized people which requires a
great deal more information transfer to
to make those parts happen it's been
realized by not just us but a lot of
people recent times the two-dimensional
prototyping is a really nice thing to do
and so I'm going to give you an example
Jer this is improving a multi-plate
vortexer to better vortex deep 96-well
blocks which is a project that we did a
long time ago anybody who's watching
this who knows anything about sheet
metal will understand that these these
parts look like they're not very
properly made and we've gotten much much
better at sheet metal since I made these
slides but the point still very much
safe even even maybe the slides are
maybe even 10 years old this is still
basically the same it's true I'm going
to think about this part in the
following way so I'm starting with a
sketch and we're thinking okay we want
to stack 3d pro blocks these are gonna
be full of E coli were and shake them
and we're so I'm gonna make a sketch I
think this is how it's going to be it's
going to have a hinge and a lathe and a
latch then I'm going to go into CAD soap
and of course is is a very common thing
that everyone has but its value can't be
too much overstated it's it's really
we're sort of a mechanical simulation is
really where the rubber hits the road
you get good at tad then actually you
get very close to the final design on
your purse attempt if you're clever and
you can iterate your design and very
quickly and can then spit out another
round
to test we'll isolate one part here so
this is one of the end caps that is
going to hold these three blocks that we
want what we then do is we unfold this
this is made out of sheet metal or it's
going to be made out of sheet metal so
we unfold it in CAD and that's what it
looks like we then export it to a
program called foam ax layout now what
is ov ax layout well it's the CAD
program for input into an Omax waterjet
cutter now a water cutter is the most
versatile of the two-dimensional
prototyping tools or two-dimensional
cutting tools the more well-known ones
are laser cutters and plasma cutters but
the water jet cutter is the most
versatile because we can cut the widest
variety of materials in fact it can cut
anything wood metal plastic rubber stone
glass wood etc and it does so by means
of a high-pressure jet of water with a
sand entrained and abrasive being
trained in the water jet which then
basically means you're cutting with a
grinding tool which is why you can cut
even hard materials which gives you lots
of interesting options here we're going
to use regular old 18 gauge sheet steel
which is about 1 on the quarter
millimeter SiC we're going to cut our
part out so you can see here we but
we've cut it out and duct a little
tubers off the edges now again this is
very beginner type sheet metal and I've
got some slits in there to help me bend
it which I don't wouldn't do anymore but
that's okay you can see that the metal
here that we cut it out of on the right
that goes back in this back and gets
used later we cut those things up like
Swiss cheese it's easy vents and also
people stock of prototype materials
around because you just have sheets of
different thicknesses of metal of steel
and aluminium and stainless steel and so
forth and then that makes life easy as
well what I then do is I have access to
or use tools that are used in sheet
metal which are vendors and spot welders
and so forth and these are tools that
are normally associated with mass
production so associated with car
manufacturing for example but in those
cases you spend enormous effort to get
the the forming tools to make exactly
what you want here we have some general
purpose forming tools and welding tools
and with a bit of cleverness in how we
design things we can make all kinds of
things using relatively simple basic
tools or general purpose tools like
these
so now I have bent and spot-welded my
thing together and I put three Depot
blocks in it and sure enough it looks
good except because we look good it
works but it looks kind of gross and
it's going to rust because it's mild
steel and so the other big thing we have
is sandblasting and nineteen house
powder coating we know how much better
powder coater than in this picture but
basically you're then painting this
thing and now it looks actually
professional enough that you could
potentially deploy it in the lab and
people could use it and feel like
they're using something that we bought
and it's all very good and and this
isn't that what we do and we have made
many many devices that we just make
powder coat and put in the lab and
people happily use them so that's the
cool thing other things we do in terms
of prototyping that are important people
always ask about 3d printing we do do a
certain amount of what I call
engineering 3d printing where we 3d
print some particularly small components
or the odd complex component that would
be part of another another larger device
the big problem with 3d printing that's
much more expensive when you make larger
pieces because it's kind of that that
that volume factor the cube of the
length really really kills you once you
get up to larger pieces but it's good
for small pieces it's also a really good
for super complicated things such as
when you hang around with hospital
people 3d printing Anatomy so we have
got a bit of we're going here to to 3d
print anatomical models for surgical
planning and actually we have a paper
we're preparing right now about the
value of actually doing this stuff so
that's cool
I do like 3d printing but I think that
3d printing from an enduring point of
view is kind of a oversold the value of
it is oversold which is to say it's
useful but it's extremely hyped right
now so so I think it's a consideration
well you couldn't get out if you're
putting together a perspective utility
what should you be spending their
resources on I think people are focusing
a little too much on that traditional
machining is something that should also
be focused on the reason is actually
most of the time in engineering you
really want to be using the right
material so these are examples I have
another project I'm not really talking
about here called them minimally
invasive fixation for the pelvis we're
making a flexible implant that can be
stiffened inside a broken pelvis once
and once it's placed correctly all of
this type of
needs to use correct materials so you're
prototyping out of hard stainless or you
know work hard in cue 16 implantable
stainless and traditional machining is
how you do that and and have that
capability ultimately it's a lot more
it's a lot more difficult for a less I
have a great capability in that area
than with 3d printing so it's a cool
thing to have
the other key competencies for my
engineering group I should Federation
finish by saying that we have with the
hospital we my engineering team we can
go and make things I can go make things
as needed but we also have to staff
machinist full-time at the hospital and
so we balance where we do a certain
amount of stuff on our own but we send a
lot of things to them and they can turn
things or because they have these
products productive tools they can turn
things around very quickly so we we can
balance our engineering design and
manufacturing activity very well other
key competencies of my engineering team
are our electronics and software
development particularly robot control
systems eletronics is maybe easier than
it used to be because arduino boards
another sort of control microcontroller
boards with various inputs and outputs
and become really accessible and
reliable and easy to use and and so we
get people up to speed relatively
quickly using those kinds of tool
control software is I will talk a little
bit more about at the end we use
typically visual studio and writing C++
for example and and the main thing there
is you know you can make nice interfaces
but then iterating the interfaces after
you interact with users is a big part
we'll talk about a little later finally
I want to talk about our current
projects now tumor closet may be okay
what you can say is we we've uh we feel
we're pretty good at the process of
library construction and the automation
around library structure right now so
now we're thinking what is the next
problem well if you're a cancer clinic
you you really find that the next
problem is how do we guarantee high
tumor content in sequencing so when I I
want to be sequencing tumor when I'm
sequencing tumor and I'm going to
sequence normal which I can get from a
blood sample I want to be sequencing
normal
so what what biopsy's look like is
something like this you'll have some
this is a piece of tissue resected I
think this is a oral cancer and you'll
have this section on the right you'll
see the formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded
block that's been sectioned and stained
so what you see on the left is a stain
slide and the the pathologist has
identified tumor somewhere around the
top and bottom
sorry identified or sheet in this case
has identified tumor at the bottom and
normal at the top and maybe we don't
have a blood sample because the patient
that we're studying here is deceased so
we want to get a normal and a tumor so
we would go and extract normal at the
top and tumor at the bottom typically we
mostly are extracting tumor and if the
patient's alive we get a blood sample so
the problem that is how do you actually
do this needs back that tissue and how
do you do that in a way that's scalable
so you can do it a whole lot we want to
have consistently high chamber content
and the reason we want to happen is we
had tumor cartridges is because you
really can't make the variant calls or
have a good limit of detection for a
rare variant if you don't have good
tumor content and that's particularly
true when you start to work with RNA
where the signal is kind of
monotonically a function of how much
tumor content you have we need to
imagine also how do we scale this thing
so so it's one thing to hand-carve a
chunk of tumor out of a foam Olympics
block but if we're talking about the you
know 10,000 metastatic cancer cases in
British Columbia which has a population
of about four and a half million or
25,000 cancer cases what can we do for
those things you can imagine you're
you're you're scaling a lot so currently
we're doing as I say here we're doing
about 5,000 clinical next-gen panel
sequencing samples and probably only
about 2,500 of those are from by also
you get our blood for raspberry and then
about 800 this person was put genomics
samples so these are really bad things
that we want to raise tumor content so
you could if you're going to raise tumor
content do laser capture microdissection
or some kind of actually could be any
kind of dissection you could actually
take a knife and cut part of this tumor
out but it's on the level of inter
mixture between tumor normal
or you could potentially just go over
and take a core and if you take a core
you're assuming it's like drilling it's
like it's like when you go and find gold
on the surface of a mountain and then
you drill a hole where the gold is on
the assumption that that's likely to be
more gold under the gold on the surface
but there is some in some other random
location on the mountain but you can't
quite tell for sure so so coin is
actually done commonly as a way to
quickly get what is probably a higher
team of content but we want to think
about whether laser capture is a viable
alternative um once you do coring by the
way then you couldn't potentially desire
a and sort nuclei if you want to study
individual nuclei or characterize nuclei
before you going to sequencing we'll
talk about that too
so remains tumor content by laser
capture microdissection and the way
we're doing with the way we're proposing
or now working on doing that is by
taking the most tedious part of laser
capture which is mapping out the
boundary of the region of interest and
automating that we're also automating
coring of formalistic tissue by sorry
we're automating the coring of
formalin-fixed tissue for clinical
panels so so this is actually taking the
part where cores are currently manually
done and doing that on a robot and then
we're doing automated desegregation of
tissue to characterize tumor content and
I'll kind of all these things so the
problem of boundary mapping is is this
we have a section and you can see here
that say all of the darker purple stuff
on the right side of this biopsy is
actually a tumor and the rest is normal
so the tumor column here might actually
be well below 50% what we need to do
then is we need to target several square
millimeters we need about actually these
numbers are a little low on the slide
here we need we need it a hundred
diagrams or ideally a little bit more
than that
so we need a few square millimeters we
can get about 10 nanograms per square
millimeter out of this stuff what we do
then is we what we have software and
exactly this is this is some basic
working in in that lab but we've
actually discovered out of this there's
a variety of
open-source tools and actually
algorithms out there and so we're
working up kind of taking some best
practice practice open source algorithms
and and going that into into improved
software that we can go and target say
the purple region and train then get the
soft ride to again identify all of the
other regions they have identified by my
blue region as the region of interest
and my hard region is the recent of
normal and I've done that because I'm I
have a pathologist who knows what
they're looking at when they when they
do this and then what the software does
is then goes out and populates the whole
rest of the slides and tells you what's
the region of interest which in this
case is blue and which is regions normal
with an orange and then you can draw a
boundary around the blue part and then
extract it so we're in the process right
now of just doing our first test using
sample two which we have whole tumor
sequencing of the normals of the
equivalent normal and we're going to be
sequencing primaries so we'll be will be
very much taking sample similar to this
and extracting several square
millimeters of the of the tumor region
and then be able to compare that against
the normal to make sure that we have
good quality supers on the automated
coring this is kind of the fun part of
an overall pipeline where you have so
this is for a panel sequencing of your
sort of K wrasse and be wrapped I Tunes
that are commonly used in cancer
diagnostics these have been all done by
a single point PCR tests in the past and
so the goal is then to merge a lot of
these things onto one panel and in fact
he'll probably including some RNA
fusions the source material for these
things is FFT biopsies and what happens
right now is that a slide goes to a
pathologist the space be sectioned off
the end of the of the tissue block but
they take a pen and they circle the
region of interest this book back to the
lab and the core the technologist you
manually align the slide and the block
and does a coring operation so what
we're doing here is we're automating
that step and so this is this is kind of
cool you
see here that in the software then you
bring the slide back from the
pathologist and they've got some that
it's not showing here but they will have
some some mark and you align the slide
and the block digitally and then target
notices this will be done as best as
possible in an automated way but the the
technologist can assist it and then we
target the region and then the touring
robot will come over and you see these
tools in the lower right corner will
come in and core the robot and core the
block and then drop the sample into a
tube ready for extraction so sorry so
the the cool part of this from an
automation point of view is is the
coring bit where you are taking a you're
doing all this automated registration of
the slide and the block and then you're
identifying the position on the block to
core and then you're going pouring it
and that's a gateway into some improved
digital automation of that where for
example that hopefully in the near
future the propellants will be able to
identify the region of interest messing
like on a computer and then we'll just
get a digital coordinate back in rather
than having the physical side come back
and then ultimately maybe there can be
automated identification of the location
of interest and then we go in court the
main purpose of the robot the Quarian
part will improve productivity in the
lab somewhat and certainly improve
improves traceability fairly
dramatically but really it also then
allows us to - then on top of that
implement an automated extraction
protocol and in black in the clinical
lab and then ultimately we'll have also
our automated library destruction and
capture kind of all on one robot
currently what's done is is manually the
extraction is done manually after the
quarry is done manually and then the DNA
comes down here to the genome Center
from the clinical lab and we do
amplicons so so this robot is actually
part of a larger plan to automate
several steps we'll have it all up with
the clinical lab and enable them to
scale the number of tests that we do
annually to some degree finally we are
interested in the use of FFPE tissue as
a tool for archival studies so you have
all of these vast numbers of samples
that are in warehouses that are
cases you don't have you don't have a
run normal for those patients to the
patient serve deceased or whatever but
you if you could get a normal and tumor
sample out of these rocks and you had
some data on the patient treatment and
outcome likely and then correlate that
with Nora profiles do you get some
sequencing you can imagine you have an
enormous resource and so in order to
enable the use of that and by the way we
we feel here in British Columbia we can
we can access those resources as a
matter of funding for these types of
projects but we can access those
resources and we collaborate well with
with our clinical partners in this but
technically what you need well one thing
is to is to assess whether you actually
have a normal and the tumor and get your
tumor content or make sure your tumor
content and your normal are satisfactory
so what we're doing what we're going to
do here is say take these sections
though this is the thing that's sort of
working in parallel to the laser capture
method of rhythm tumor context so this
has some advantages will disadvantages
and we're going to do both of them and
see which kind of comes out better this
one certainly can work potentially with
more material but it's hard to actually
change the tumor content of your tumor
content azaab what we're doing that is
we is we bring in course we decided it
and we have some automated methods for
decided getting them into individual
nuclei it's rarity it sells out of FFPE
by the way we're fresh frozen for that
matter it's much easier to get the
nuclear because the cell walls kind of
stick together so you get nuclei out and
then we can actually take your allowed
lots of these things and we can drop
them onto a slide and we can image them
and attack on our robot we can image we
can actually drop 96 of these onto a
slide so we can make an automated
pipeline of coring output into this
aggregated tissue and then into little
outputs that get spotted onto a slide
and then image and this is an example of
a few cells and then we have working
with calaman colleagues library or
colleagues at the Cancer Research Center
here we they've developed software to do
automated analysis of these of these
cells and so it can actually subdivide
so these these are two sets of cells
they've been imaged and then subdivided
into into into normal and Tetris and
this is the same scale so you can see
that the ones on the left are much
larger these are
so be easy to identify or convert to the
right ones which are the ones on the
right which are normal but it can then
tell you your content of the normals and
your content of Okuma so so that will
then enable us as large-scale to
potentially prepare large numbers of
samples in which the tumor normal tumor
content and the normal content is known
which should be very helpful to these
large-scale studies um so these are I've
described a number of automation
projects that we've done and I think
we've looked some lessons that are I
mean these may be obvious lessons but
they're there they're still good lessons
and we still sort of keep finding
reasons to think about them and apply
them um we do really believe in the fast
prototyping concept the first version of
barracuda the site selection robot that
we built when from concept to my current
elibrary construction came in five
months so I came back to her conference
thinking we needed to build this thing
and had it in production for micro RNA
in five month the there was almost no
CNC machining required to make that
prototype everything that we used on the
robot was either purchased or scavenged
like but other words commercially
manufactured parts and/or it was made on
in our 2d prototyping pipeline and and
so this is I think particularly an
automation this concept of 2d prints
typing where your water jetting stuff or
real primarily kind of stuff out that
way it's particularly good indication
when you're building automation because
there's so many components of for
automation that are commercially
available you can put together almost
everything you need except for your sort
of specialized pet components and and
it's very very efficient and then
actually a realization that you you try
not to build your own robot rather do an
add-on to the existing robot so in the
case of Barracuda we started with a
deceased qmix
so this goes back to about 2006 the
robot was older than that we actually
pull the stages out of it and left them
on a shelf until 2009 we started
building Barracuda one and then we had
to build a chassis that looks exactly
like the original cupids chassis because
of course the robots are certainly
shaped and you're going to use the robot
according to the shape it has then we
built another back up versions of dark
Widow South America - and we had to then
recreate this scavenge thing using we
could scavenge
these stages and built with chassis and
then we then we had to use new stages
because we couldn't get more of the
older stages and so we had to build new
stages in a new Safiye but when coastal
genomics is part of to become an idea
the spin-off company that has
commercialized the site selection
technology it was realized that actually
we could adapt a commercial liquid
camera to do this and in fact the
Hamilton Nimbus in this case and not
only that but we could then go from
having one pipette tip and loading the
sample one of the time to learning
samples 12 at the time and and
subsequent to that we realized that that
in fact other projects we want to do
it's going to be easier to adapt a
commercial liquid handler to the
application rather than building a
custom solution and then that also gives
you the advantage of the downstream
liquid handling options that you can use
and so if you that corner grow bottom is
describing earlier that unit is a
another Nimbus that we were able to
actually make it we have a special tool
that we made that can the gripper can
grab the pipette tip holder but the
array of 96 mandrel can grab this tool
and go in core FFP blocks and drop off
these these cores and then we drop that
tool and we can pick up with the same
head regular pipette tips and do regular
liquid handling and so this means you
can build a essentially two robots in
one and from a from a commercialization
point it's just the practicalities of
not having to build a very complicated
and expensive machine which you don't
have to support is being extremely
attractive and finally and I think this
is quite well known to everybody but
it's interesting in the context of
robots that robust software takes time
and the interesting thing about it for
me especially being somebody who's more
mechanically oriented is that it takes
much longer to develop robust software
that it takes to develop robust hardware
so we sort of feel now that it takes
five times longer to make the software
sort of final version compared to making
the mechanical part of the robot
essentially on any for that matter the
electronics the final version so that's
quite a an important concept that you
have to to schedule in or or think about
when you're do your development cycle
and so for example with our courting
robot we have a plan two together
working at a basic level and be able to
deliver it to the clinic for four for
initial validation after say six months
of the funded project and then there's
maybe 18 months or two years of
iterative development the may
involvement actually going out and
getting subsequent funding to do further
development but we can keep iterating it
and improving not only the robustness of
a software user interfaces so it works
maximally well for the users having said
that and I think this is also an
important point here the in-house
devices can run in an underdeveloped
state if the developers are in the same
building during production operations I
think a lot of places actually do this a
lot of factories that have their own
equipment do this and it's not an
unreasonable thing to do but if you're
going to send something out in the wild
you certainly are looking at that five
times more labor than your veneer
mechanical component on that note I
shall close I'd like to thank you my
groups deep levels and Dwayne cause
transpiler sorry filled style and
ecology water and our technology
development partners to do Memphis
development here at the GSD and all my
other colleagues the liquid thanks very
much thank you so much for that
informative presentation Robin we want
to get right to the audience's questions
and input so here's a reminder to our
audience as to how you can communicate
with us questions can be submitted via
the Q&A button at the lower left if you
are unable to get to your questions due
to time constraints Robin will reach out
to you via email so let's take a look at
our first audience questions we have one
here that says are you doing any smaller
volume pie pitting in live
Construction no sorry a small garden
pipetting not in not in general library
construction at this point no we're not
sort of doing to try to do large numbers
of library constructions for say
bacteria which is you know need to be
low-cost although that's an interesting
area we have been looking at low volume
pipetting for single-cell genomics and
so can you scale down I mean I think
other people have demonstrated this but
but but picking about methods
development for for single-cell RNA see
can potentially met trips P for example
in so yeah we are looking at that and
work with some sub microliter or say
some non leader pipetting using nano
wells size place and I think that's an
interesting area we have one more
question from our audience members what
are the future developments in library
construction for you
well what one area that I mentioned
during the talk that we hadn't really I
think looked at automating incubations
and I think actually there upon
reflection and upon you know being at
some recent conferences and so forth be
there is certainly now the software the
next step is to is to look at more what
we might call fully rockaway automation
where you're going to you're going to
actually automate not only sort of
setting up incubations which maybe means
some kind of liquid coverslip it means
ideally you could and this is
particularly working with some of our
partners like the Center for Disease
Control locally here can you get away
from you know separate equipment for
shearing and doodoo shearing on deck
with chemical or enzymatic means and if
you can do that you know then can you
basically do really end-to-end
automation so so that's an area that I
think there's a bit of development to
where there's fruitful developments be
done when one thing there is really the
robot programming the error handling or
checking to make sure that you have all
your tips and that everything's in the
right place is because going to become a
lot more stringent so you have to think
about whether you know do we need to use
onboard cameras and then definitely
intelligence around analyzing your you
know taking a picture of your tips and
making sure all your tips are in place
or being able to image the wells that
you're working on and make sure they
think it looks correct so we have to
think about some of those things Thank
You Robin do you have any closing
remarks you'd like to share with the
audience before we close today
I have a lot of passion for this area
and I thank you for listening and I hope
that you know you've got something
something out of it I think you know all
of us who work in automation in for Life
Sciences it's a really exciting area
that's always exciting to share things
that we've done within our labs for
other people
Thank You Robin coop I'd also like to
thank law groups for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
until August 2017 keep an eye out for an
email some lab routes alerting you when
this webcast will be available for
replay we encourage you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event thank you
again for joining us and we hope to see
you next time
buh-bye